this week two key figures in U.S
politics have generated some headlines
in no small way because of their age
yesterday house Speaker Nancy Pelosi
announced her plans to step down as
leader of the Democrats in the house at
82 Pelosi said that the hour has come
for a new generation to lead however she
will keep her seat in Congress no plans
to retire
and on Tuesday former president Donald
Trump made it official announcing that
he is again running to be president of
the United States now Trump is 76 he
would be 78 if the voters were to give
him another chance to move into the
White House
Trump will be spending the next year or
two on the campaign Trail no retirement
for him either
and what about the man in the white
house right now Joe Biden has a birthday
coming up a big one on Sunday the
president will turn 80 and if you are on
social media you know what I mean when I
say that many think that gray is getting
in the way
some consider Biden too old for the job
but is he or are they being ageist and
thinking rather old fashioned
it's moments like this
or when Biden makes the leaders of
Cambodia and Colombia and I want to
thank the prime minister of Colombia's
leadership in the aseans asean chair
that raised the question is Joe Biden
fit enough to hold one of the world's
most demanding offices at Biden Jr
with the unexpected success of the
Democrats during the midterms and the
defeat of nearly all trump-backed
candidates it seems more likely than
ever that he might run again Our
intention is to run again that's been
Our intention a second Biden term would
guarantee a measure of stability for the
International Community
he stands strong with Ukraine and
maintains a solid position against
Russia's threat Russia will be making an
incredibly serious mistake
for to use a tactical nuclear weapon
he's also convinced that fighting the
climate crisis is a crucial
responsibility for his own country
the United States of America will meet
our emissions targets by 2030. and he's
apparently seeking a way to work with
China China and the United States can
manage our differences
prevent competition from becoming
anything every near conflict
and to find ways to work together on
urgent Global issues that require our
mutual cooperation
they are still nearly two years to go
before the next presidential election
the chances of a possible Biden win are
highly dependent on his opponent he
could face a rematch with Donald Trump
in order to make America great and
glorious again I am tonight announcing
my candidacy for president of the United
States
but Trump's run has triggered an
internal fight among Republicans over
his future role and that Republican
divide might help Biden's party God
bless you all thank you
regardless of who runs for the Democrats
[Music]
and that was Carolina chamoy their
reporting Carolina joins me now from our
studio in Washington D.C it's good to
see you Carolina I want to talk about
President Biden in just a moment but
let's talk about politics in general in
the U.S there there is a very a large
number of
elderly older older Baby Boomers in
American politics what explanation have
you heard or what explanation can you
give for that type of demographic being
in power so long
well Brent as you know getting into U.S
politics is quite expensive it can cost
up to Millions to start a political
campaign here in the United States this
is one of the reasons but also once
these people get in there and they are
in the Congress representing their
constituencies
um they tend to to stay there because
there is no term limit so this is why we
see this baby boomers as you just called
them in the Congress but this is slowly
changing because some candidates and
we've seen that in this year's midterm
elections have been able to get into
congress with crowdfunding models or
Grassroots organizations for helping
them in their campaign like for example
the first gen Z congressman who has been
uh is now in office and he's going to
start in Congress next year in January
but we have been seeing this also with
Alexandra ocasio-cortez from New York so
there are some young people who are
starting to change this very slowly but
traditionally the ones who run for
office just have a lot of money to start
a political campaign in the United
States that's true and older Americans
do have more money that's true that the
numbers are very clear about that let's
talk about the President Joe Biden he
will turn 80 on Sunday
um is that an event that will be marked
in public is there going to be a lot of
fanfare or is that something that will
be rather quiet and private
well I think he would like to keep it
quiet uh he's not marking that day he's
not marking his birthday the white house
isn't either but people are marking this
day because it's not just a birthday of
a U.S president it's the 18th birthday
of Joe Biden and with that he is going
to become the oldest president in U.S
history so there is a symbol behind
behind this birthday as well and of
course the question that everyone has in
mind uh is is he going to run again this
is why people as you also mentioned on
social media especially are marking they
say is an important day he's not going
to have a big a birthday party but a fun
fact brand is that his Grand
granddaughter is going to have a big
party at the white house because it's
her wedding this Saturday and she's
going to be marrying there at the White
House law that's not bad to have a
grandfather who can throw a wedding
party for you at the White House and I I
wonder you know it's nice if you can if
you've got those connections I wonder
I'm if we place maybe too little value
on the wisdom that someone can bring to
the table when they are 80 years old
regardless of politics Joe Biden seems
to personify that someone with a lot of
experience and and does does that make
you think I mean what have you been
hearing is he going to run again in two
years and do people value that
experience and wisdom that he would be
bringing with him
I think some do value his wisdom and his
experience especially now we have a war
going on in Europe and a very divided
country over here we don't know if he is
going to run again for the Democratic
party but he said that he is going to
make a decision by the beginning of next
year and we are already hearing
different names like for example Lincoln
the Secretary of Foreign Affairs or
about a digital Secretary of
Transportation who might also be
considered as candidates for the
Democratic Party
yeah I mean a lot is going to happen in
the next two years that is for sure and
we'll go ahead and wish Joe Biden a
happy birthday in advance Carolina
Washington Carolina thank you